president Trump's former lawyer is
making it clear that he is willing to
cooperate with the special counsels
investigation into possible collusion
between Russia and the Trump campaign
Michael Cohen claims then candidate
Donald Trump knew about a 2016 meeting
at Trump Tower the president's son his
senior advisor and son-in-law Jared
Kushner and his former campaign Chairman
met with a Russian lawyer the Russian
allegedly offered to give them damaging
information about Hillary Clinton just
moments ago President Trump tweeted he
did not know of the meeting with his son
Paula Reid is at the White House Paula
good morning good morning sources
confirmed that Cohen is willing to
testify to Special Counsel Robert Muller
met then candidate Trump knew about the
Trump Tower meeting in advance but these
sources also tell me that Cohen has no
hard evidence to corroborate this
testimony that he is offering now
president Trump has repeatedly said he
only learned the June 2016 meeting a
year later when he was already in office
but if true Cohen's allegations would
undermine repeated statements from the
Trump camp denying that they colluded
with the Russians it is important to
note Cohen has credibility issues here
he is currently under criminal
investigation for his business practices
in that tweet from the president just
moments ago he makes references to taxis
taxi medallions are part of what Cohen
is under investigation for and he's
offering this information in hopes that
he will get leniency in that case over
the past few weeks we have seen this
remarkable shift in Cohen's legal
strategy he went from sort of stoic
silence to this very public break with
the president he has hired an attorney
who is most famous for helping the
Clintons through their various legal
issues he is leaking evidence to a news
organization that is frequently the
target of the president's criticism and
here you have this very public
acknowledgement that he is actually
willing to flip on the president now the
big question is whether or not Special
Counsel Robert Muller is going to buy
what Cohen is trying to sell and the
fact that Muller has pretty much passed
off the entire Cohen case to another US
attorney suggests that perhaps the
Special Counsel does not consider Cohen
to be a valuable source of information
Gale thank you mom we want to put this
in the context of why this would be
important why would it matter if
President Trump knew about this meeting
beforehand it wouldn't matter because it
would suggest the president knew that
Russians were coming to offer dirt
against his opponent that is a crime in
other words that you are that you are
cooperating with a foreign government to
undermine an American even though they
are your opponent in a campaign and
that's why it's significant I think
that's a very important point and the
president continues to deny that that's
right thank you
to be continued